so bridges has 24 points on 11 shots
he's six of six from three
closing into double figures and rebounds
as paul pulls up so that's
two big baskets by chris paul
seven assists for jokic seven rebounds
25 points
paul again driving pulls up
again that's three big buckets down the
stretch
from chris paul where he works his way
into that 12
15 foot area for the pull-up
all screen from jokic murray keeps it
drives against eight and sweet move by
jamal murray to get to the rim
and it's a two-point game again
[Applause]
murray feeds a cutting yoke missed got
it back
goes back up and scores with the left
hand to tie it at 114.
smaller line up here for denver
[Applause]
yokish great pass to harris
harris with the left hand scores
here's a terrific pass and drive and
finish look at that left hand
book around the catch of the elbow they
double him bridges
drives tough shot off the window hayden
is there with a follow jam
bridge's corner three that's his first
miss he was six
of six from out there loose ball johnson
gets on the floor
finds aiden for the dog and a foul what
a play
by cam johnson he's not had a great
night
offensively but brooker first going up
for the second
shot cam johnson to the floor first
and then finds ayton for the three-point
play this is winning basketball
denver by one pick and roll murray and
jokic
murray trying to shake bridges pull-up
is good
denver by three
that shot from jamal murray looks a lot
like some of those baskets we saw
in the bubble he's got 16 points denver
with a three-point lead late in overtime
that's just a big time move by murray on
the pull-up